oh that's the boat I got a pic with you
don't watch that who you point that yeah
that's a two-hour long phone you were
waiting oh my god
I got a bone to pick with you and
Indians well it's really not hauling
because I wish you [ __ ] would know so
it's not this Indian Patel guy it's John
Kapoor have you heard of him nah this is
[ __ ] on the stress of know his
name is John well here's the thing
he's I guess from India comes here and
he's like one of the people that's
responsible for the offense in all
crisis in America son
I was watching 60 minutes on it mm-hmm
son this is a evil [ __ ] bro
I believe it man he calls himself John
don't trust no [ __ ] in breaking up or
get the [ __ ] out of here you know so
this much so this [ __ ] what he
did is he essentially I don't know if he
owns fentanyl or whatever the [ __ ] it
was he can look it up but what he did is
he got out these like these people who
sell or basically kind of like bribe
doctors to prescribe certain medication
mm-hmm so they're pharmaceutical reps
yes what they do so I guess he
represented Fenton all our own fence or
whatever it is but he set up this whole
representative team to get doctors to
prescribe fentanyl okay and he would
reward the doctors that prescribe it
describe it more and he put them on
these like speaking tours whatever like
that where they get money to speak
because you can't pay him directly but
you only spoke if you prescribed the
fentanyl and he would have data
analytics of how much that he was
prescribing to the people and he would
only continue to reward them if they
upped and increase the amount of
fentanyl he was prescribed per person
Wow
so and those people and those doctors
were told and if you do not continue
only giving this person five milligram
or micrograms or whatever it is up into
ten they need to have more he literally
forced addiction through doctors on
these people and these scumbag [ __ ]
doctors who were going along with it
were part of it and it was just this
unbelievable 60 minutes piece obvious I
have to find the other side to the story
but it was one of those moments where I
sat back and I was like
week I don't know if capitalism and
health go together be real talk like had
to give it so clap there yeah annex it
exposed it like I want doctors to make
tons of money because their job is so
[ __ ] important I want them to get
paid so much goddamn I'm one of the best
people to be doctors and I want the best
people to be doctors in the way you
reward that is with a capitalistic
system right monetary gain that being
said when you create a situation like
this where it's in people's best
interest to make them addicts yeah
you're just as bad as those drug dealers
on the street matter of fact you're
worse because those drugs is on the
street no they're coming to get illegal
drugs
these people are trusting a [ __ ]
doctor to give us something to make them
feel better yeah and like I can't waive
wait for the day of reckoning we're like
the veil is taken down from the
pharmaceutical industry it's crazy I
used to work in on oncology what do you
call this [ __ ] in Congress like the
lobby the pharmaceutical Lobby is like
the [ __ ] last the most powerful words
no one crazy mountain but you were
saying you were so I used to work in an
oncology office and we had some like the
top oncologists like top of their Yale
Harvard all these types of doctors these
[ __ ] and I knew this was going
on um for trial
chemo drugs they were incentivized in
that same exact way to get as many of
their patients to get on these trial
chemo drugs even though it's it's almost
like I would say 90% of the cases you
see those patients deteriorate faster
because these chemo these trial drugs
are so much stronger than the approved
chemo drugs that are in place right now
but these guys would get bonuses they
would be at all he's speaking the
arrangements this [ __ ] getting
a million dollars per speaking
arrangements Wow son it's crazy the [ __ ]
that's going on in the medical system so
worries so that's what do you have to
say about that cuz you're Indian law for
your people
yeah searly if you see an Indian defund
India with a Indian glass that we
already did that
with indian how the king's a defunding
y'all different continents go if you see
me with an indian last name and a white
first name do not trust this guy bobby
jindal bobby jindal if you see a [ __ ]
william super super money in or whatever
the [ __ ] knob brought you out i don't
trust you at all he's doing that for
white people and that's not indian you
trust mmm-hmm interesting you out what
it is you're saying they changed their
name or the parents not his given name
he calls himself that so you guys trust
him more [ __ ] but in reality he just
wants you to be able to pronounce his
name because it's probably hard to
pronounce so he manipulates the you
pronounce it right so he almost change
the whole name i know the name kapoor
there's not gonna be it's not gonna be
that hard yeah [ __ ] two syllables yeah
but that's really [ __ ] up that he
would just change the pronunciation of
his name just to like get the masses to
be able to accept it more you know what
why are you looking to me
mark gag could you pronounce it
what how else could you pronounce it
mark gallo or whatever the [ __ ] yeah no
they're saying it wrong how is it going
you just want this [ __ ] to be closer to
[ __ ] i'm john make you guys comfortable
anyway it is crazy man it really opened
my eyes to like the is there no way
around that in a socialist medical
system or like I think Medicare
unfortunately the solution is an extreme
amount of government overreach and that
is gonna limit the amount of drugs that
we have but I really think that drugs
kind of like are like porn in that like
we kind of figured it all out like we've
done all the drugs like yeah we need a
vaccine for this illness that's out
right now yes do we need a vaccine for
restless leg syndrome no do we need a
million different drugs for you're
overweight and you don't want to stop
eating
no the drug for you're overweight you
don't want to stop eating is you stop
eating mm-hmm like why are we creating
to enable the problem that you have so
what's interesting is they tried to shut
a lot of this down there's it just seems
like another loophole and maybe they'll
always find loopholes but I remember my
uncle used to get gift cards for
everything fancy dinners all the time
paola liquid radio yeah only people's
lives are at stake and you can't there
has to be some kind of like monetary cap
because it seems like it's the
pharmaceutic a purse a Lurie's high it
would still be a competitive job I think
if the if the compensation for a family
practice doctor is three hundred fifty
thousand a year all right I'll do that
if it's a million a year for a
neurosurgeon salary all right I'd do
that but all these incentives that's
where the problem is if I just get a
high ass salary I will still want to be
a doctor but all this other [ __ ] that
you don't even know about that makes you
think I want to be a doctor yours that's
where you got to cut out you say right
so don't you also think that like people
are naturally greedy so if there's an
opportunity to make yeah it might still
take and the problem I think is gonna be
the farm I think you got to go to the
pharmaceutical but even their salaries
they're incentivize the more patients
they get so yeah so you want to let
drunk on spaces like incentivize them's
like oh yeah you have our retention rate
and you are bringing more business to
here you get a bonus I know and I don't
know what I know that's a thing and I
also think in a social system it will be
like we want you to see as few people as
possible because we have to pay for all
this this comes out of our pocket every
time like people are naturally greedy so
what is the solution there is an
imperfect solution whatever it is I
think I don't know what it is we I think
we all acknowledge that there is
conflict right yeah between capitalism
and health yeah right and it is a really
tricky thing so we have to do something
to limit the extremes of capitalism yeah
when it comes to health specifically and
I think we usually limit the extremes of
capitalism when it comes to like most
businesses right you can't have
monopolistic practices child labor laws
child labor laws even minimum wage like
there are things that we put in place
here so we need to have a little bit
more and it's weird for me even say this
but government overreach on the
pharmaceutical company's ability to
reward a doctor you're using their drug
yeah and is that Veils not gonna get
lifted for decades probably because
there's so much other [ __ ] that's there
that we are dealing with yeah we're not
gonna look at that for a long time
hospital administrators are apparently
greedy [ __ ] like they're not giving
their nurses masks and [ __ ] like that
because it's just like our mom that's
pathetic
this is I'm sure you guys can poke holes
in a solution but like what if we gave
detail I know this might be against
HIPAA but what if we gave an analysis of
what happened with the patients that
that doctor saw not specifically by name
but for example 60% of diabetes patients
that saw this doctor ended up you know
reducing their diabetes and bla bla bla
bla bla bla and then we found out there
are certain doctors they were like oh
90% of these patients that went and saw
for back pain ended up being on
oxycontin and being addicted and having
problems like okay well I don't want to
see that doctor cuz analytics for whom
like a third-party agency that over like
oversees all this yeah like it's almost
like yelp review for doctors but we get
to do it based on what they're
prescribing and how they're treating
those patients so that week ago well
[ __ ] I want to be with that doctor who
he seems like all his patients not all
are 60% of his patients end up
recovering while this one 20% of his
patients end up recovering 80% become
drug addicts poke holes in it I'm trying
to think of a private case it would be a
private company which is good because if
it's a government agency they don't
they're lazy by nature government jobs
are right me and Elena do [ __ ] really
private company could be incentivized to
get it done but like how are they
incentivized for them to stay completely
moral and transparent then they should
be bribed by the yeah mark yeah it's
tough it's tough like that's the other
thing with like these forms to a company
you can try to find them like johnson
johnson got fined 500 million this is go
on I know where you're going with this
and this is really important people
understand so go on so like the this
drives me [ __ ] crazy Oklahoma ruling
for Johnson & Johnson with their role in
the opioid crisis they were charged 500
million dollars how much did they make
off of the drug it's difficult to say
exactly but in the light of magnitude of
greater than that like in the billions
so essentially these drug companies are
going I don't mind if I get fine 500
million dollars for the drug that may or
may not work if I can make a billion
yeah mm-hmm I made five hundred million
dollars I made that's five hundred
million less yeah okay I'll make nine
hundred million
900 950 whatever that [ __ ] that the
number is who knows I made 500 million
dollars right that's how right so it's
like all they have to do is calculate
that punishment in it's simple it's
probably no different than like the
banks right like okay if I sell up the
cell these [ __ ] up things and I do
this bad [ __ ] if I sell people bad
mortgages or you know I can't pay and I
take that loss but think of all the
money I made on interest and/or even if
the SEC finds me yeah I don't care they
fine because they're not gonna find me
more than the amount of money I made the
punishment has to be greater than the
amount of money made yeah and maybe
should go to the point where they can't
make any money off of it yeah yeah like
even this dude Kapoor wasn't in John
John Kapur yeah sixty six months in jail
how many years is that I got five five
and a half I mean to become a
billionaire you wouldn't do that or a
hundred millionaire whatever the [ __ ] he
was where his family keeps a lot of
money like I think you have to remain
you're out on good behavior and here it
is and also there's very few people that
actually get like actually tried yeah
that's right it's hard to catch up so
here's the thing maybe we do this if
financial incentive is the reason why
they're doing it right we have to remove
all the financial reward in the
punishment for the crime yeah so now you
wouldn't consider doing the crime
because you're like well I'm not gonna
do five years and I get no money out of
it yeah but I'll do five years and be
worth 100 million yeah but like how can
you prove that the speaking engagement
was payment for giving these meds you
can't but you can
disincentivize the company that would be
hiring the guys to do the speaking game
engagements if you if they knew that
they could get punished and have all
their profits removed if the drug ended
up being fault if white-collar crimes
punishments were purely like [ __ ] jail
time it's all financial and it is
heavily penalized financially you might
not even be worth of it because if you
got if your punishment for money
laundering is we take all your money I
don't know how much you can prove
whatever we just take it all I don't I'm
sure that's an overcorrection because
they can afford the attorneys too so
that's writing these rules won't pass
because the people who break the rules
are rich and make the rules so this is
all some [ __ ] that would never happen
it's you wrote me an idea this is
something they're really interesting
maybe we say is for patreon cuz we gotta
wrap this up but but we just you know
put it
out there and then go check out patreon
of patreon.com/scishow and to you know
[ __ ] army growing like crazy almost
an tan yeah we're almost at 10k man so
we're coming we come inform bro so let's
get up that's it if you're listening
right now you [ __ ] with us go check out
that patreon man and if you don't
believe us telling you go listen to the
reviews go listen to other [ __ ] army
members that [ __ ] with the patreon and
they'll tell you for themselves but this
is discussion we should have over there
when it comes to cancel culture and we
got a shout out to miles the guy I think
was miles or Orion brother that miles
brought this up to us when it comes to
cancer culture it's really interesting
we do not keep that same energy for the
people who commit white-collar crime
you